hello Internet so I've heard that too  but when you dunk it in water the  frequency vibrates the war in a cool way  that looks good in slow-mo yeah oh yeah  so have some choices for you dad do you  think it will look a really crap and not  good be rubbish or D really awesome  really awesome first alright give it  right whack and a great work right there  yeah let's go whoa  you have some serious bloody splash yeah  serious splash back it's like the  smallest little bit oh that's severe oh  my god my vid no exaggeration  well luckily for our YouTube channel  oh that's all I could be it was actually  option D that was correct it did look  awesome and I just discovered something